but uh this doesn't quite cut it as a
proof it's attractive and we've got the
intuition now laid out
but it's not enough because i've sort of
intuited
based on the question and the result
that i've been asked to prove that
you have to go up right that's what i
expect this this wants us to do
but i don't actually know that for
certain because if for example
you think about moving from this value
here we said that you've got an x value
of three
and then as you move to the right this
graph is going up this graph's going
down and i expect that that
means when i add them it's going to
increase right
but you need to know that the amount
that you're increasing by
here is going to be bigger than the
amount that you're decreasing by
here now you can sort of see because my
graph is roughly the right shape because
of this hyperbolic structure that we got
you can see oh that looks ish like it's
going to be increasing more
than this is decreasing and that's why
you have a total increase
but you don't actually know that you
actually have to say can i prove that to
be the case
what knowledge do i have access to which
can tell me how
quickly things are increasing or how
quickly things are decreasing
that's right you've made the connection
i'm going to need to appeal to some
calculus here
right i've got to show that this
gradient here is going to overtake this
gradient down here and that's why you
have a total increase
and the reverse is true on the other
side okay so
this doesn't constitute a proof by
itself but it does give us a map in our
head of where we need to go
i need to show essentially that at this
spot right here
that has to be a minimum turning point
that's what i'm after
right if i can justify that then i can
say oh well therefore that's the lowest
you can go and you're just going up from
there
um and therefore you can say that this
graph
the object once graphed will be greater
than or equal to two-thirds across its
relevant domain which is between 0 and
6. so you can see why like i said
this is not as efficient as our previous
algebraic method if you know what to do
algebraically
algebra is often the most efficient way
but i still think it's really useful to
try and push on this and see how we can
structure proof around it
so now we know what to do how do we go
about this well
i'm going to take this statement here
right
and i'm going to work on this with
calculus and see what we can get from it
right
so i've got y and i'll just twitch it as
you didn't need to zoom like that
i'm going to put that to make it easier
to differentiate i'm going to put that
into
index form so i've got a to the power of
negative 1
plus 6 minus a to the power of negative
1
and now we are ready to go it's not
going to be d y
on dx like we usually get it's d y on d
a and uh off we go let's start to
differentiate
so i'm gonna get in the first instance
uh minus a
to the power of negative two brought the
power out the front and then
reduce the power by one same deal here
for the next term but i'm also going to
have
i'm going to have chain rule going on so
function of function so here comes the
derivative of the outside i'm going to
do the same thing i'm going to have that
power come out the front
i will reduce the power by 1 and then i
multiply by the inside derivative
because i just did the outside
derivative and convenient for me for me
being that the inside function is 6
minus a the inside derivative
is negative 1 so i'm going to get some
handy dandy cancelling here
and here that's nice to know so what i
got
i've got negative 1 on a squared
i just said that those two negatives
will cancel so i get plus and then i've
got 1 over
6 minus a squared all right
so i'm trying to show that i have a
stationary point here right i haven't
had a question that's told me
find uh you know locate stationary
points and determine their nature but
i've decided
that that's what i need to do so
therefore i'm going to get this in a
form that makes it easier for me to
identify stationary points
let's combine these two fractions into
one
for starters common denominator so i'll
put that minus 6 minus a squared over
there
and then i'm going to go plus a squared
on that side all divided by
what have i got here so a squared
6 minus a all squared on the denominator
that looks good
really all i need to worry about is the
numerator when i'm trying to solve for
the first derivative being equal to zero
so let's
leave the denominator in that sort of
factorizy form
and work on this uh numerator here so
i've got
minus outside of let's see i'm going to
get 36
minus 12 a plus a squared
and then i'm going to add a squared and
as i pointed out nothing is going to
change
on the denominator things are looking
good if you remember where we're headed
because remember i'm anticipating
a stationary point here at a equals 3
and maybe you're about to see what's
going to happen here right this
a squared is actually there's a minus
sign attached to it
from out the front and so it's going to
cancel with this a squared which is
positive
and so that leaves us with minus sign
will attach here
this will flip around with a double
negative so i'm going to write that out
the front
12 a minus 36
and then i've got all this stuff on the
denominator which is not that
interesting to me at least not yet
so hooray i have a first derivative and
remember what i'm looking for
is a turning point right so i can say
turning points
may occur you can't say they're turning
points yet even if you solve
for um when that first derivative is
equal to zero because you could get a
horizontal point of inflection which is
not a turning point so they may occur
when that first derivative d y on d
a equals zero i'm going to disregard the
denominator because no matter what the
denominator is equal to it will never
make the whole thing
equal to zero so in other words i'm just
looking at the 12
a minus 36 and as we anticipated
you're going to divide through by 12 and
yet lo and behold
a equals three hooray that was what i
was hoping for
on my graph that i got it so it's nice
to know that our intuition and graphical
approach
has sent us in the right direction i
haven't actually shown that this is what
i want but it's a
minimum turning point so i've got a
turning point occurring there
and of course i can put that in to get a
y coordinate um which i will do in a
second though i already know its value
but i look back from my potential
turning point and i say i've got a
choice i can either
do a neighborhood test check the
derivative on one side versus the other
and then show it's you know decreasing
zero and then increasing with regard to
gradient or i can do second derivative
right and then show something about
concavity
when i look at this derivative here do i
want to differentiate this again and the
answer is
no thank you to do quotient rule on this
looks like it's going to be more trouble
than it's worth
and i think it's going to be fairly easy
to do these substitutions so i'm going
to
check the neighborhoods so check nearby
values
and in this context um you know checking
on either side just by one unit so a
equals two
equals four that should be more than
sufficient so um
a equals two what's that going to give
us d
y on d a is going to be equal to
when you substitute that in you're going
to get up the top there 24
take away 36 all divided by
um let's see 2 squared is 4 and then
6 minus a is 4 but then that gets
squared so that's going to be
16. so i'm getting -12 on
64 which i know i can cancel but i don't
need to
because that is going to be less than
zero ie
being this is the first derivative this
is decreasing okay as i was hoping
and then i just need to rinse and repeat
for the other side of my potential
turning point so i'm going to check a
equals four and uh there goes d y on d a
and unsurprisingly because of the
symmetry of this uh
12a is going to be 48. that looks
familiar
take away 36. here on the denominator
instead of getting 4 times 16 test it
out for yourself when you can see what
the denominator is going to be equal to
you're going to get a squared which is 4
so it's going to be 16
times 4. so it looks familiar and that
gives us 12
on 64 which just like before i don't
need to simplify further because that's
enough to say
it's positive in other words it's
increasing
okay so what have i got here if you want
you can draw yourself a quick
table of values for values of a versus d
y on d a you're getting from two to
three
to four we have this negative twelve
then the zero then the twelve so you can
clearly
see the shape that we were anticipating
earlier
so there's the decreasing zero and then
the increasing
so it's fantastic so i should tidy this
up because that looks a bit messy
doesn't it there you go actually put a
table around your table of values what a
normal idea there
that's a little easier to read and so i
can say
therefore uh you know i'm going to put
the coordinates down here right
a equals 3 and it's fairly
straightforward to see
where extension 2 students i think we
can say by inspection at this point
when you put three in here and three in
here you're getting like we anticipated
graphically before
a third plus a third so that will give
me
two thirds is
a relative minimum now
we do need to point out because remember
this is a proof
just because it's a relative minimum
doesn't mean it's the minimum
so we should actually state there are
two things that need to be taken into
account
to show that this relative minimum is
absolutely the minimum
within this domain the first thing is
within this domain from naught to six
there's no discontinuities you notice
that i've actually got a discontinuity
right on one side at zero and the other
at six and the reason why that's
important is because if you had some
graph that looked like this
uh it's a weird looking thing but
there's a discontinuity there and i ask
you hey where's the minimum
right you could find by calculus what
this location was
you could show that it decreased then
zero and then increased but it's not the
absolute minimum because this
discontinuity means
on the other side you have no idea
what's going on right so there's you
know there is no minimum to this
function because it just goes down
forever
so firstly you need to say there are no
discontinuities
and then secondly i'm going to say but
in this domain from naught to six
let's say that before we forget it the
the function
is continuous us the other thing you
need to know
is that there are no other turning
points right because
if we were to find some other like we
found a relative minimum if we found a
relative
maximum somewhere what that would imply
is that here's the minimum but then the
maximum turns around and that means you
can drop even further
you know this part of the graph is lower
than this part of the graph right
so therefore i need to know there are no
other turning points which i can say
off of this solution path here you see
you've got that linear function on the
numerator
only going to have one solution one zero
so the function is continuous
and there are no other turning points
no other stationary points means there's
no other turning points in this context
no other turning points that's what i
get for talking and writing at the same
time
so therefore it is an absolute minimum
as well
and you know ordinarily you know if the
question was to
uh locate stationary points and
determine their nature this kind of
detail might not be necessary
but i have to i think it's you know the
the onus is on me to say this because
this is a proof question right i need to
show beyond a shadow of a doubt that
two-thirds is the bottom
and i have to be greater than or equal
to that value
right so therefore i can say 1
over a plus 1 over 6
minus a has to be greater than or equal
to two
thirds within this domain from naught
to six and then i'll conclude by back
substituting i put in six minus a
so i could turn this into a function of
a um but therefore i can say
that a or the 6 over a rather is
actually b
and that is the result that i was tasked
with
proving as required
full stop so in conclusion what can we
say here
this is a delightful question and a
lovely way to solve it i think even
though
yes i know it's a little bit long
because we had to pull out some fairly
heavy-handed tools to do it
but a few things to say number one it is
always valuable to push
on a mathematical object to say if this
is one way to solve it
um is there another because you didn't
know from the outset that this would be
slower i i did because i've done this
before but you know you may see a
solution
and then see another one and think which
one is the way to go
and by practicing this and getting
fluency and sort of sensing oh okay
i actually have other tools at my
disposal here that might be useful
you may end up stumbling upon a solution
that is faster
secondly there are going to be other you
know tasks where
other questions where going to this
visual and
calculus approach is not just faster it
might be the only way
that is immediately obvious or the
question itself might sort of
lean you in that direction it might say
like here's uh you know part a
uh find this derivative and then part b
some inequality appears and you're like
what's the connection between these
ah and this might be it okay uh and
lastly
i just want to point out i think it's
delightful that a tool that we've
developed
um and and learned to understand which
is you know differentiation
finding stationary points all that kind
of thing the question itself
said nothing about differentiation or
finding turning points determining their
nature
this is a skill that you're used to
applying because someone asks you to
but here it's a skill that we can apply
because it is useful
to us when you want to show that
something is going to be greater than or
equal to something
you can find its level's value and show
that it has to turn around there
and there's going to be no way it can go
beneath it and calculus
rates of change gradient is what helps
us understand that
so help you i hope you found that uh
method of solution
insightful and that it's useful for
tackling
questions in the future and just general
problem solving skills